Pope Francis has promised to take action
on child abusers in the Catholic Church
only weeks ago it was revealed that
nearly 400 priests had been dismissed in
the last two years because of suspected
molestation of children but church
policy is to investigate the allegations
internally at the UN Committee says
that's not good enough another matter
was the code of silence that was imposed
by the church on children and the fact
that reporting to national law
enforcement authorities has never been
made compulsory the UN report estimates
the number of victims in the tens of
thousands it says the church has failed
children the main finding of the
committee was that the Holy See has
adopted policies and practices which
have led to the continuation of the
abuse by and the impunity of the
perpetrators the Holy See has
consistently placed the preservation of
the reputation of the church and the
protection of the perpetrators above
children's best interests the committee
also criticized the Church's position on
homosexuality contraception and abortion
it's calling for an overhaul of vatican
policy